[Arabic recitation]
we would to discuss
an aspect
of
the of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
which is
most feared upon the Muslim.
This is according to who? According to
our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
who speaks
from revelation
and that is that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam himself
says
he said the thing I fear most
over all of you
is the minor type of shik. Now
let's take a a moment here to appreciate
this categorization.
Our prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
informs us of a category of shik. A shik
what is a shik? A shik is the opposite
of
ifhed is the worship of Allah alone
without any partners then a shik is
anything that compromises tohit. This is
referred to generally as shik. Anything
that will compromise
the worship of Allah
alone without any partners is considered
to be a type of ship. And this
compromising
it can be compromise
the entirety of a person's
meaning if a person does this they have
completely compromised theirhed and
their Islam is invalid
or it compromises an aspect of their
which means that their tohed is
deficient lacking and incomplete when
they meet Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
You know what we had? Yeah,
and so
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam tells
us of a category of shik which is minor
shik. Now there's nothing minor about it
other than the fact that
it is only minor compared to its major
counterpart.
When we say minor shik it doesn't mean
that it is
something to thumb your nose at.
Minor shik is shift and Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala generally says
However,
minor ship
is only minor compared to major ship.
Major ship is that which will invalidate
the entirety of a person's Islam.
Minor ship is that which will invalidate
a portion of a person's and islam. And
so when a person meets Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala without having repented from
this, they will meet Allah with their
being deficient, with their testimony of
Allah being incomplete,
with their fulfillment of the worship of
Allah alone without any partners as
being missing
critical and crucial parts.
And so this is one of the greatest of
problems and tragedies and calamities
that could afflict any of us.
In
the prophet
tells us in the narration of Abbas and
he says
He says in my is more subtle and
discreet, more unnoticeable
than the footsteps of ants on granite
rock.
How loud and intrusive and sorous are
the sounds of the foot footsteps of
ants? Has any of us heard an ant? you
know walking around, barging around in
our house. No, of course not. But not on
any material but on granite rock. Subhan
Allah. This ship is more subtle, more
nuanced,
more hidden
in this than the footsteps of ants on
granite rocks.
And so this is a warning from the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam that we
have to learn what these types of shirk
are and then we have to steer clear of
them. We have to put in an active effort
to steer clear of them. So what is this
type of minor shirk that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was so
worried about over his
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
He tells us
that the shirk that he fears
over this ummah even more than
even more than the than the false
messiah that will come at the end of
days claiming to be
and leading people astray in droves.
Wasam.
[Silence]
He narrates to us that the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam said, "Shall
I not inform you all of something that I
fear over you even more than I fear the
fitna of
for you?"
They said, "Of course, oh messenger of
Allah." He said that subtle hidden
shirk.
A man will stand to pray and beautify
and adorn his prayer and exaggerate his
prayer because he feels or he senses
that he is being watched by someone.
This narration has been collected by
Imam Ahmed. We refer to this as a
which is that a person
behave performatively in his worship
of Allah in order to garner praise.
So a person stands to make salah.
They're by themselves. They're praying a
certain way. But then they feel like
someone is watching them. All of the
sudden their salah becomes very
righteous.
our salah becomes
super
focused and righteous and you know
exaggerated.
This is referred to as aryah
meaning literally that a person show
off.
But there is even another way that a
person
can invalidate his salah, can invalidate
his can invalidate his hard work, can
invalidate his worship of Allah even
after he has done it for the sake of
Allah alone.
A person stands to make salah at night.
A person gives anonymously.
A person does something for the sake of
Allah alone without any partners.
And he does it where no one was seeing
him. And so he is safe from a reality.
But then
he starts to tell the stories about his
heroism
in private.
Right. The journey of the hero
who marched through the depths of
darkness
worshiping Allah alone even though no
one was there to see it except for
Allah. This is called what
a
is literally bragging.
If a person does something for the sake
of Allah
and then brags about it and then
mentions it
with any intention of garnering
respect
or garnering
attention,
then this will retroactively
reach back into the past and invalidate
a man's good deeds.
and validate a man's hard work.
Why?
Because generally speaking, Allah
Subhanahu Waaala said in the narration
of
Muslim,
I am least in need of a partner.
Whoever does a deed
and associates with me another in his
intention for that deed, then I will
leave him with his partner.
I will leave him with his partner. I
will leave him to get his reward from
his partner. There's another narration
in which the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that on the day of
judgment it will be called out
everyone who has worshiped Allah
but had intention
of other than Allah along with him.
Get your reward today from that other.
Go and get your reward. Collect your
reward from whoever was driving your
intention.
This is a danger, isn't it? It's not
just a pitfall. It's positively a live
landmine.
It will completely obliterate a person's
hard work.
You see, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala does
not need us. We need Allah in every way.
And when we work hard and do things,
we are doing it in the end for our own
benefit. We are the ones that reap the
benefit
of our hard work and the worship of
Allah.
[Silence]
He says, "And whoever strives, works
hard,
then he is really striving for the
benefit of his own self,
Allah is not in need of any one of his
creation." Subhanahu wa ta'ala. So when
a person does something,
it is absolutely paramount
that his or her intention be solely for
the sake of Allah alone without any
partners
and that he continue to protect
those deeds
with his tongue. that he continued to
protect those deeds by not bragging
about them later.
And this is something that is extremely
common. This is why we see
that the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam feared this over the general
population of his more than
because
he will be endured by a finite number
of people. He is he is the the the
destruction of his fitna is largely
confined by the time and place that he
is. However,
the whisper of a shaitan
to
whisper into a person's heart into a
person's chest
that people need to know who I am. They
need to know my struggles.
First of all, it's silly.
The reason that it's silly is you could
be bragging to someone about your heroic
feats and that person you're bragging to
has done twice and three times more. How
silly would you feel at that point? And
I guarantee that that person is out
there. If you made a hundred at night in
PM, there's someone out there that made
200. And if you made a,000, there's
someone out there that made 2,000.
That's the way that this world works.
None of us is actually the absolute best
at everything. It doesn't work that way.
And so if you knew that the person you
were bragging to has done multiple
multiffold
what you are bragging to him about you
would feel very silly and this is only
one of the pitfalls of bragging or
showing off with one's worship. We
worship not because it benefits us now
or benefits someone else. We worship
Allah solely to garner the pleasure of
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala. And it's not
enough to just say I am doing this for
the sake of Allah as a as a
disclaimer before you start in your
stories.
I am
[Silence]
going to step through.
And just a reminder that starting
tomorrow will be at 4:15.